the flames above these oil fields burn
around the clock here in the Niger Delta
there are countless oil wells it's a
lucrative business and accounts for
around 70% of Nigeria's state revenues
as Africa's largest producer of oil
Nigeria is confident about the future
the continent as a whole boasts huge
reserves proven oil reserves in Africa
total more than 130 billion barrels
currently production stands at around 9
million barrels a day the top oil
producing countries are Nigeria Libya
Algeria and Angola they account for
around 84 percent of crude oil
production in Africa the oil producers
could use the revenues to finance
development programs and modernize their
economies but very few countries on the
continent are benefitting from oil sales
Nigeria is no exception
it's Africa's leading crude oil exporter
but the country is plagued by social and
political conflicts despite the high
revenue from petroleum exports many
people still live in poverty
for the youth you got software you know
a rampantly corrupt ruling class has put
much of the country's oil wealth into
its own pockets in 2013 Nigeria's
state-run oil company in NPC produced
and exported 2 and a half million
barrels of oil a day that brought in 65
billion dollars an investigation later
found that over 19 billion dollars of
the revenue was unaccounted for those
responsible have not been punished if
used wisely revenue from oil exports
could be a driving force behind economic
growth in Africa but so far that has
seldom being the case changing that is
one of the biggest challenges facing the
continent
you